[Applause]
[Music]
C and slice however we need there we go
we're good so this is my farm this is
the chicken pen area but so it's feeding
time I gave him some vegetabl scraps and
some extra raw milk this morning but
this is my awesome coup everybody's so
ready to get out oh I love it okay oh my
God I can't wait to see this like 3
chickens getting out in the
morning
yes oh my
gosh look at that
they're like be free little
chickens oh my God how do you get them
all in there at night I'll walk you in
there I'll give you a little
tour I love my
yeah yeah this is so this is like my
dream I want to farm so
bad visit this is so cool love to share
it this is like the best place in the
world I think but um yeah
I think so it's a little rainy today so
it's not you know the clouds look kind
of cool it's big old Circle up there but
um yeah this is the farm this is my
heaven on Earth it does it does
exist it's
beautiful that was
awesome
yeah this is like favorite place how do
I change this around this is confusing
okay so let me give you a little tour
you know so the roosting bar
roosting bars is the floor we give this
a good pressure hose every month or so
but um yeah so egg boxes we're about to
install two more today these ones oops
come out so this is where they lay their
eggs in the
morning um's gonna come out thiso look I
already have
one get ready to lay I'll see if
anybody's laid any eggs in here this
morning yeah business is
usual so this egg box is amazing because
this helps keep our eggs a lot cleaner
we still have our our few whereas some
like come out are dirty we still get
quite a few that are dirty but these egg
boxes are the best ever this is where
about this this has
AAC chick they all sleep to them it's
the roosting bars off the ground but to
us it's like the ground in here but my
husband built this by hand all by
himself wow proud of him for that wow
here they go here they go yeah it's
incredible soon they're all G to be like
it'll be like boom boom boom boom boom
like all of them will be in there you'll
just hear singing all day there she goes
oh my
goodness oh that is so cool yeah I'm
trying to figure out how to flip my
screen I don't know how it won't let
me um
oh there might be a little flip button
or
something yeah it's not no that's okay I
think when you started recording it
wouldn't let me flip it I think we're
stuck oh well we can what if I pause it
yeah I can stop and cool so for everyone
that's listening right now this
[Music]
is witness the most exciting Morning
Experience with all of the chickens and
I'm like wondering how do you get them
in at night I'm thinking of like chasing
them we just want to welcome you yeah
thank you yeah that is awesome
absolutely so we just wanted to get
exclusive insight into your life your
business and everything that you're
passionate about we got to connect in
Iowa I got to hear the pitch it was
absolutely incredible you got an egg
washer that is going to be coming at
some point it's goingon to change your
life so first before I just I bet so
walk us through what inspired you to
start this the farm or just in general
like chickens or well anything yeah I've
always really had an Infinity for
animals um as a kid I am I've always
brought home stray animals all the time
animals are just a love I have uh it was
it's a natural gift that I was didn't
realize until I was 36 and so I've been
begging and begging for chickens for
like pretty much our entire relationship
but military lives we don't always have
time or space or the housing or the
neighborhood and
so finally 2020 hit and you know my
husband had just gotten home from a
deployment yeah I edit so you're good
you're good I really wanted to show you
the chicken part so I wanted to be out
in the field I'm trying to get out of
the field now so you can have like yeah
so it's like my favorite part of the
morning so we 2020 hit and my husband
just came home
and I was like yes now's my time for
chickens he has nowhere to go and we're
stuck here so I'm quite persistent um
with students I really love and that I
really know I want and um so he was like
all right let's get a few backyard
chickens but we have to do it right so
you know it was a neighborhood it's not
our forever home we had to make a nicer
Coupe which was you know actually helped
the resale value which was great but um
what we but yeah we got chickens we got
like six okay I li chicken math is real
y'all we got 10 I was like yeah yeah
yeah go to the farm go get some chickens
and bring them home I'm like okay cool
I'm only going to get six that's all we
need and then you see them and they're
there and you're like I need more than
six so
I and he was like what are you doing you
said six and I said what I what if some
die you know I heard that's a thing and
so you know 10 became eventually 20 in a
little backyard where I'm only legally
allowed to have six but like I kind of
paid off my neighbors with eggs so it
worked out it's fine it was fine and so
no absolutely and it was great I wanted
chickens originally just for eggs I had
no clue the genuine effect it would have
on my mental health um and it funny
thing is it all started with a funny
little bird that my husband named
murderface and she's the one who started
it all for me uh she laid me my first
blue egg and she was the weirdest friend
I ever had and anytime I felt sad you
know I'm a veteran I've got issues like
every other veteran and um I would go
out there just to be alone and just
listen to my chickens and it was one of
the most therapeutic things for me they
weren't snuggly like a dog they didn't
want me to pet them all the time they
just want to be at my feet and pecket
stuff and just be next to me and I'm
like this is nice so yeah I found in
love hard like real hard and I kind of
became a crazy chicken lady to where now
I have this really kickass
Farm I just feel so blessed by it all
the time that's how we got here we my
husband's about to retire and we're like
What do we do and he wanted to go
Contracting and I'm like no please don't
do that I don't think I can handle that
anymore so can you reconsider like why
don't we be farmers and like his initial
reaction you know was like what that's
too easy no way and then I'm like well
just think about it so and then next
thing you know I hear him doing YouTube
videos and he's like yeah let's do this
like all right I'm in I see where you're
going that makes total sense he he saw
the magic on the YouTubes and he was
like right on board with me um from the
beginning and it was just amazing um I I
took a shot in the dark with him I
thought he'd say no and he surprised me
so wonderfully in like the greatest way
and it's I came here I came here out to
pinland for him as a Green Beret I
didn't want him to retire and completely
lose everything about himself because I
made that mistake when I got out and I
only did six years I left everything
that I knew behind and everyone and it
was not a good thing not at all a good
thing and so I had to figure out what I
had to do the hard way and it was not
kind and after 20 years I couldn't
imagine what that would be like for my
husband and I chose this area for him
mainly because as a Green Beret you know
you need your identity still you can't
just take that away and that's so
ingrained and I felt like you need to be
near your people they're my people too
now so let's go this is a great place
I've already worked out here as a as a g
fighter in pin land um that's a gorilla
Fighter um Pine Land is a fictitious
country that closely res resembles North
Carolina and it practice uh they teach
soldiers unconventional warfare in the
Special Forces World and it's really
valuable and I get to work so side by
side with some of America's future
finest like we know one uh Benjamin bun
you know he was a for former Special
Forces man and you know and that's
that's such an honorable job and um oh
oh check this
out this is my beautiful Diamond can you
see oh my gosh I've seen the videos yes
I can see her a pretty girl yeah so the
Farm's always on there's never stopping
on the farm so a lot of people come or
like they don't know about Farm Life
they're just like oh well don't you have
like a few minutes and I'm like yeah I
got like five and then in those five
minutes something's trying to kill kill
something else or the like it's really
awesome when before I came to the farm I
actually had like a really hard time
with life before I came here I suffer
from like really bad PTSD and my figh or
flight is always engaged it's all the
time when you live in a city it's not
the best place for someone like me no
I'm always on guard I'm always wondering
what's that what's this it's like it's
quite I can't fix it there's nothing I
can do um but being here on the farm
like fit here like I found a place where
I belong because my on it's appropriate
here and I feel so calm knowing that
this is a place where that's okay this
is a place where I can let that be free
because something's always trying to get
killed here and something's always
needing some kind of Defending from
something else and if it's something I
can't turn off well then let me use it
in a good way in some way and so it's
been really helpful mostly like all like
it's always been super helpful most of
the time there are times where it gets a
little out of hand because it's a real
situation and I'm like oh my God this is
oh lot I wasn't prepared for this what
like my first time coming across
something okay yes Hi here's Teddy yeah
so it's really nice to find a place that
I feel like my Brokenness isn't broken
it's been really beneficial to a lot of
my healing and a lot of things that I
didn't know existed until I got here and
I left the city and I saw the difference
and how much release of tension because
I was able to actually do what I've been
taught to do but wasn't untrained how
not to do anymore so yeah I I this is my
heaven on Earth I do feel like those
places can exist for people you just
have to find
yours yeah I love message sending yeah
it's a great message for everyone and I
know that you're always trying to spread
knowledge too and education on you know
like I I had the privilege of actually
hearing the pitch and not everyone who
went to the shower gets to hear these so
I mean like about milk about um the eggs
in general like what sets your eggs
apart like what talk talk us through
that piece because it's very
interesting well I think a lot of people
can do what I do I don't feel like I'm
special I will say that I think think
what's the most important that I don't
feel like I truly got to because I I've
never done a pitch I was so nervous I
didn't no I was so you know it's my
first time yeah the message that like I
really wanted to bring out was that our
food issues in America are very real and
they're very scary 2020 woke me up to
that very much and it's just it's a
trend that's happening and it's
happening more frequently bird flu Aven
flu Oh now the dairy cows have problems
oh the meat there's something wrong with
meat there's a valid argument to the
people who don't want to eat meat
because they think it's bad for you well
yeah the stuff at the grocery store is
bad for you don't eat it you are what
you eat eats if what you're eating is
eating garbage and labade stuff then of
course it's going to cause you problems
they have a valid argument but the
farmers you know when you're a big
business there's only so many farmers
that own and run everything my eggs are
regenerative raised they're pasture
raised they're on grass I mean they have
that huge giant field it's actually
double the size it should be by standard
and I feel like it should be bigger but
you know but anybody can do what I do
lots of people all over America are
doing it already but the only difference
that I'm trying to bring with my eggs is
that I want to deliver them myself
directly to the consumer like to the
groc store and say okay here's your eggs
these are fresh these are the freshest
that they can get we will come and
deliver bi-weekly because I want to make
sure my customers have fresh fresh is
always better nutrient count is
nutrients is important for your health
and the longer an egg sits the less
nutrients dense they are which means the
less benefits that you get in your body
running like every farmer should be a
soil farmer um for instance White Oak
pastures you can look them up online
they're really amazing they are super
big into this and they're trying to
change the beef industry as well and
they're trying to change the way things
are done everything's monoculture
everything is just one one one but
that's not Mother Nature that's not the
what God intended everything's supposed
to go together in harmony like live
together so we can mimic that with with
grazing with appropriate grazing I'm not
thinking of the right word here um
rotational grazing Y and it's easily you
can very easily mimic it you can't do it
with machines you no farmers can never
be replaced with machines we are one of
the most valuable Assets in this country
whoever controls the food controls the
people and I'm not okay with that yeah I
want I don't I believe there's another
there's so in the industry of eggs eggs
sit and by the time you get your eggs
from the grocery store they're like
almost two months old that's old in my
book I wouldn't eat two months old eggs
I mean I do have the grocery I didn't
know any better now no I wouldn't not
one a bit I'd feed it to my animals I'd
feed it back to them to regenerate give
them back you know what protein what's
left but I like nothing goes to waste
here you know and so I want to model
something different I think we can do
better I know we can do better there's
Farmers All Over America who can do
exactly what we do and regenerate the
world people are talking about pollution
and all this crap and they're blaming on
cow farts well you know why don't you
change the soil cuz everything when it
rains all that water evaporates a lot of
it evaporates in that monoculture
situation and like how do you think
that's handling in our environment about
helping a lot yeah if we change the way
we're farming we could change a lot of
things and it's just not natural what
we're doing it's not healthy either Aven
flu happens because of dirty conditions
and then it spreads very quickly because
it's contagious so avoid the dirty we
haven't had one issue with our birds not
one
not one health issue none of them are
vaccinated none of them all of them are
all natural just chicks here you go
byebye go me some eggs we supplement
every once in a while with a little feed
but we try to supplement with more raw
milk than anything but that's only like
winter time summertime they're you know
they get raw milk they might get extra
eggs that we didn't sell if there are
any left over and what we want to do is
we want to do a model similar a lot of
other Farmers that are doing it but we
want to like Empower them a lot of small
farmers don't have a way to get their
name out there yeah they don't like for
instance vital Farms vital Farms is a
really good idea they are a wonderful
practice however they've now are gone
big in corporate and so many people
don't want corporate anymore so many
people want their neighbors but their
neighbors an hour away and they can't
always drive there but we can we can
deliver and we want to bring other
Farmers to join us but we don't want to
take away your name we don't want to
take away your identity like vital Farms
I think what they do is great but they
slap their name on someone else's hard
work yeah and then they take a
percentage it's like an affiliate
program they take a percentage from them
so the more money they make the more
money they make cool story but why not
just let that family have it and do it
different let them pay the fees or
whatever that needs to be done to fall
under you and under your your guidelines
and such but that's their label at the
grocery store that they can be proud of
that's their family name out there now
in the world and after a certain amount
of time you know and they learn what we
do we want to teach them we want to
empower them we want to we want to bring
them out to the world like we want to
try that we're trying to bring ourselves
out there but we feel like if we have
more we have like an egg Army of small
farmers just like me who want to put
their name out there let's do this and
let's do it together let's put your name
on the front of that box and mine on the
side on a little code let's do it
backwards like complete opposite from
vital Farms like flip it around one it's
their name that's awesome and their ours
is on that tiny little code on the back
you want to know more about fin my D
blah blah blah visit this website you
know but that's that family that's their
honor that's their pride their hard work
and they deserve to show it to whoever
they want to show it
to you know as long as they're within
the guidelines and the standards and
they pass the inspections and they do
these things why not give America back
the power take it back if we're going to
fight back if people really want to
fight our government back you don't do
it with guns anymore you got to be
smarter than that you got to play their
game how do you control the people you
control the food yep
and I keep hearing that you know Farmers
like they I mean it's good to hear that
they still exist but it sounds like it's
getting to be a smaller and smaller
number of people doing it and of course
like you said Corporation everything
comes down to money power control um
just like yeah so it's a very scary
thing and I mean food is everything food
is food is medicine y so it's incredibly
important I think this message is very
important as well so I kind of want with
Warrior Rising like we talked about a
little bit about your background and the
far itself so how did Warrior rising or
was it the academy was it the community
experience what value did you get from
being a part of warrior rising to help
your farm there's a few things I got
from that from that whole experience all
of it good I'll say that first all of it
great having that automatic feeling of
like hey welcome we got you come on and
I i' never met any of those people and
every single one of them was so
supportive every every single veteran
like we're all in competition together
but then I was like wait what this isn't
oh this is oh I like this one this is a
good one um I love working together even
though like at the end with still a
competition you know that's my style all
day you know it's all great everyone's
there everyone's still a winner everyone
you know you go home with relationships
you go home with knowledge having my
brain stretched in this way has just
been revitalizing I was able to open a
door in my mind into a passion like this
has been my passion for a while but the
way that this expanded my mind was not
what I expected it was I I purposely
came um with no expectations because I
didn't I didn't want to have any and be
let down because that's what happens to
sometimes with people and I chose to
like kind of hide myself from a lot of
it just because I wanted to just I
wanted to be wow and I was I was floored
I was more than wowed girl I was floored
yeah so touching for me having such
overwhelming kindness and love just
thrown at me was just wow it floored me
I went there for eggs and I came home
with just the money yeah the money's
great I am not that's amazing but like
if I had to do it all over again and I
didn't get any money I would feel
exactly the
same um the people I met the things I
learned oh wow the things I learned
wow um yeah it was just I'm
Lord I highly yeah it was a very unique
group yeah that that group was so
collaborative so um and that was my
first business shower as a part of the
warrior Rising team and I was absolutely
just overwhelmed in a good way with how
kind everyone was to each other and how
the competition was more supportive I
mean everyone wanted to see the other
person win and wanted to know more about
that the industries were so diverse too
you didn't see two of the same things
there so it was really incredible so um
I know you got to get back to your farm
but if there is a small farmer out there
listening right now or someone who's
into agriculture what would your advice
be for them to start or to to stay the
course when things get hard well for one
to get started um research do all the
research you can before you jump in have
an idea of at least one thing I will say
when you get on a farm and you're like
Yay you want to do all the things I'm G
tell you don't do it hump your brakes
hump your brakes my friend don't do it
start with one get real good at that one
before you move to the next one because
it will very quickly overwhelm you it it
will it will catch upop with you real
quick we towed that line when we first
got here but that was because we didn't
you know when you get livestock like
goats you have to have more than one and
so they're quite chaotic little
troublemakers so we came here with a
plan we knew we wanted to come for a
business we knew also knew we wanted to
come for like our forever home and so we
were very strategic our forever had to
have job opportunities just in case our
Five-Year Plan didn't work because in in
any true business you have to have a
five-year plan if by you're five if
you're not successful you should
probably throw in the towel you know and
choose something else because you're
just going to be throwing money into a
bucket that has a hole and so with the H
of warrior Rising like we are oh wow
we're we're really getting that that
like we were on our way but it's it's
going to move a little bit faster now
and our dream's going to come a little
faster now and when you choose your land
Choose Wisely don't choose cheaply wise
is always better know your area no flood
zones planning is super important before
you jump in yeah that's my biggest key
advice if you're married and you're
going to do a business together you know
you should you should get a little
counseling before you do that depending
on your relationship because it'll test
you it's basically like having a baby
only like magnified times 12 because
it's extra work you have to rely on each
other it will either make you or break
you and I feel like it's making us which
is really awesome awesome yeah because
SF life was hard and it was breaking us
but the farm is remaking us and it is
probably one of the most beautiful
gardens I've ever witnessed to start
growing in my life after the Army every
single one of the people in my family
has found some kind of Freedom here and
some kind of peace and it's really
kickass that's incredible I love hearing
that for you and your and your husband
so last piece of advice now
veterans trying to start their own
business veterans wanting to be
entrepreneurs what is your piece of
advice to them this is not my quote this
actually comes from of another farmer
called the shepherdess she's down in
Texas she does sheep but I will I will
quote her think big dream big let me say
that again dream big start small and
never quit I have been telling people
around here hey man one of these days
you know we're going to get some where
you wait this is my dream this is what
I'm going to do I promise this is what
I'm going to do and I can't tell you how
many people have been laughing at me but
I can't tell you how many I can tell you
how many people have stopped laughing at
this point and if s of been like oh oh
she might mean
it so she's serious yeah yeah yeah our
farmand um he comes every once in a
while to help us out with a lot of like
like digging and stuff and he he I told
him my dream I was like Bryson you stay
here with us if you stay with us you
stick with it this might just be a real
job for you and he's like really what
are you doing and so I told him my dream
and I told him I wanted to do and be in
the grocery stores I showed him
everything and where we want it and he
just kind of laughed and was like all
right yeah good luck he stopped laughing
yeah good and that's like the best
feeling ever so absolutely you're doing
it you're making a difference y yeah you
really are for regenerative farming I
love this I have such a fire in my belly
for it and I just want to have I want to
empower other Farmers small like me you
can do it too come with us we'll show
you and when we're done when you're done
with us you don't have to stay with us
you can if you want but you can go off
on your own too you know we want you to
be free yeah I want to get people back
some of that absolutely I want to try to
help that freedom yeah depresso leave
absolutely I mean yeah there you go yeah
you're making a huge difference though
and it's something that I can align with
the the Health piece and like our you
know food is medicine like I said so I
appreciate you putting doing what you do
and empowering other Farmers to do the
same because I think the more that we
have that the more power we can get back
to the people um and our health and
taking control of our own lives so
without um taking too much time because
I know you have a massive Farm to attend
to Sophie thank you so much for sharing
us and letting us come to your farm
seeing the chickens come out and and
sharing with us the amazing story and
the amazing incredible impact that
you're making on your community
absolutely absolutely and there's always
more to come from us we have we got
Tricks our sleeves girl you just wait oh
I cannot wait and this is not the last
time we'll be talking and I always look
forward to seeing everything you post I
feel like I'm at the farm and I'll have
to come visit and actually get some
footage out there too I'm like yeah I'm
like because it's something that I've
always wanted to do but that's for
conversation for another day but no
thank you so much for letting us be a
part of your morning yeah I hope you
have the best day ever thank you for
joining Warrior Rising thanks you too
than AB much Warrior Rising for
everything uh where can everyone find
you if they want to see what you're up
to or how they can buy eggs yeah so we
are located in Siler City North Carolina
SI city um we have two locations that
we're currently selling at right now we
also do farmers markets as well uh
chattam Meco located in Syler City and
Sanford um we are actively trying to get
into Sprouts right now um the the Whole
Food store and we can be found on
Instagram and on Facebook at Pineland
pastures Farm I hope you guys check us
out and if you want more information
about what we're doing please head us up
we'd love to share what we're doing
absolutely thank you again Sophie and
for everyone listening thank you for
tuning in this has been another
incredible voice that makes Warrior
Rising the premier place to be as a
veteran entrepreneur bye guys
oh
[Music]